this week i'm joined by evelyn this week
it is chocolate chocolate who doesn't
like chocolate yeah he doesn't find
chocolate we'll try three different
chocolates at drastically different
price points to determine which is the
most worth it okay
if you lay all the toblerones in the
world back to back some of them would
sink
it is lovely look at all this
we're in arlo
dam
we're running late
hi hi how are you doing
i woke up with the idea that i would
take bars we enjoyed as children but
remake them with great ingredients dark
chocolate smoothie fruiting hunky dory
crawling wunderbar coconut hocus pocus
lovely fruity crunchy munchie
my name is james ecclestone i'm the
founder of the grown-up chocolate
company we're standing in my production
kitchens in harlow we have the very best
ingredients we're making an indulgent
treat we're handmade focus on the
quality of what you're doing so it truly
is a handmade process did you just get
that off a tray
we don't mind the chocolate addicts
salted peanut caramel is 40 of all our
sales first making a cavity of 38 cocoa
milk chocolate we make a cavity because
it has to be filled with fresh green
caramel the caramel we make with
concentrated butter full fat cream
glucose and sugar put that caramel in
the bottom of the cavity we've made from
the chocolate add some coarse sea salt
jumbo roasted peanuts then we cap it
with peanut praline we cut that cavity
with more milk chocolate and we rub it
on the machine behind me goes through a
chocolate waterfall one of the better
word
then we blow off the chocolate with a
hot air dryer after that somebody
decorates it with the chocolate
sprinkles the third person unloading the
tunnel boxed up for retail use and off
to their destination today you're gonna
be trying the peanut salted caramel
retails for about one pound ninety-five
maximum indulgence let's do it let's
indulge
nice try kid but it's not for you two
bars of sumptuous salted caramel what
does sumptuous mean i like tasty or sexy
sexy sexy
you're sitting pretty selfishly right
now we've seen these go through the
whole process they did a better job on
that one than that one i guess that's
the art of making it by hand they're all
different they look exactly the same
this is a nice heavy solid chocolate
isn't it oh it's already touched the
mouth i can't cheers
[Music]
cheers
rich powerful chocolate we have the hard
chocolate on the outside perfect milk
chocolate this chocolate is so buttery
and instantly melt in your mouth salted
caramel which really is salted it's not
too sweet smooth sticky nice that white
stuff is the peanut pure hard-hitting
peanut taste isn't it right kind of like
gritty slightly salty again balanced
really well with the chocolate
all of the good things packed into one
little bar
one big bite truly sumptuous the joe of
chocolates i don't know if i want to eat
this now
so i think this next place has the
coolest name of all places ever chuggy
woggy doodah
in brighton i just picked you working
there and answering the phone hello
chuckywockydoodah
it kinda sounds like a magical play yeah
so i had to use to live in brighton and
i went away for a week and my roommate
left my window open and i came back
there were like twigs on my bed and like
it smelled really weird and then under
my desk this massive seagull terrifying
luckily it was fine but then i closed
the window and then he would come back
like hammer on the window and look at me
but you're in my room stole his house he
stole my house
we're here in sunny brighton in the
middle of summer lovely english
[Music]
just been mugged by a pack of thugs you
know having a bad hair day and it's not
sunny and sunny brighton
the beauty with what we do is we stick
chocolate to chocolate with chocolate
it's like an art gallery but it's all
made out of chocolate it's all 100
edible
pretty fun right so i'm dan we're at
chocolate dude in brighton we're an art
and design focused chocolatery we pride
ourselves on making cakes that like defy
gravity
i notice you called it a chocolate or
it's not chocolate shop we're not going
to throw you out if you call us a
chocolate shop what's the difference oh
don't ask me that i don't know it's yeah
it's french
this one here took a team of four three
days to make holding his thingy a lot of
the magic happens at our studio it is a
top secret location do you have in
palumbos we don't have an polymer so
today you're going to be trying our
chocolate rocky road it's quite a
mouthful as we like to say chunky
walking rocking road chugging walking
rocky road trucking walking rocky road
literally everything that's fantastic on
its own covered in chocolate nougat
honeycomb coconut ice jelly beans and
marshmallows
we mix everything together in a giant
bowl we'll set that in the fridge once
it's set we drizzle it with molten white
chocolate once that's fully set we'll
take it out and then individually wrap
each bar ready for sale in the shop so
today you're going to be trying our
enormous bar of chocolaty rocky road and
it's priced at 29.99
this isn't a bar this is a slab
oh it's like unwrapping a christmas
present
oh you just get hit with the smell
[Music]
so beautiful
oh
look at the marshmallow
right that's your bit this is my
birthday
i can see marshmallow coconut ice jelly
baby thing some fudge cheers
it's the best thing i've ever put in my
mouth
it's not like an overload of chocolate
physically heavy
taste wise light
and the texture changes throughout soft
marshmallow
coconut ice it's more like a fudge and
the jelly beans are becoming sticky yeah
and the honeycomb is crispy
it's like a new chocolate bar every bite
isn't it it's becoming more difficult it
feels slightly greedy but satisfying
sorry but this is mine i mean this thing
is ridiculous chocolate fact in mayan
time the cocoa bean was actually used as
currency what could you get for one bean
it's like a tenner
but what if they were different sizes oh
it was extrusive no i don't know well
you need to find this stuff out is that
a fact man what's the source of that
don't tap your head now
so for this next part it's kind of weird
when researching expensive chocolate the
most expensive is from a company called
toac that's based in ecuador you can buy
it in the uk okay but liz wouldn't let
us go to ecuador i'm sorry joe where's
ecuador
yeah okay we will not reveal where this
chocolate bar is sold we have to keep it
secret we're going in here
chocolate joke chocolate jokes
i was struggling to open my chocolate
easter egg eventually i cracked it
[Music]
that's a good one that's a good one
yeah
oh my god most expensive purchase of
chocolate
[Music]
hi
i'm kyle and i'm calling you from koak
headquarter in ecuador torx tries to
elevate chocolates on the same level as
best whiskeys and vintage vines we work
with a very rare variety which is on the
brink of extinction called nacional the
indications that it's the oldest cacao
variety on earth take the beans into a
drying facility once this is done you
drew roasting rid of the shell grinded
into refined chocolate liquor adding
sugar and grinding it down again it's
like really smooth liquid chocolate you
know the magic is in the details i would
concentrate mainly on smelling it and
once you place it in your mouth let it
melt
and breathe through your nose same like
with wine this is when the magic happens
how does it start what do i smell what
do i associate it with so today you're
going to taste our chocolate which is
priced at 300 pounds
is the most expensive chocolate in the
world
it's like you've opened the tomb
i feel like indiana jones this is so
posh
oh
that's 300 pounds of chocolate right
there i feel like i'm touching goat
well the little tweezers this fancy
contraption is it's for eating the
chocolate because our hands are not
worthy
okay let's take you off
you're eating something so special you
whisper
yes
harvest year 2015 like wine there's a
year for it yeah what if it's out of
date
oh my god there's a
being in the middle there's a bean
it's like a game of operation
look at that
and just for the rarity of these beans i
think
john's also cool this is super expensive
right but it is just chocolate they
haven't done any of the gimmicks like
paint it in gold or put it in a diamond
i mean the packaging is beautiful and
it's lovely but it's much more to do
with the chocolate
[Music]
to me it smells like this amazing old
study with a fireplace and two big old
leather armchairs like some old books
and it's all warm and cozy in there
there's a glass of whiskey on the side
and there's just this old wise dog sat
by the fire who just sort of looks up
that's what it smells like
[Music]
honestly
there's definitely a high that's why
it's so expensive it's lacey drugs
you drink wine the initial taste is
slightly different from the next taste
and it changes again and then you have
an aftertaste it's exactly the same with
this there's fire there's ice there's a
heavy there's light yeah i definitely
got some chocolate in it the james bond
of chocolates are effortlessly cool
quietly epic quietly epic chocolate i've
got like 50 pounds worth of chocolate on
my fingers which of the three amazing
chocolates was the most worth it for you
i love the way to add so much depth to
the flavor it was like having an
incredible bottle of wine gotta say
gotta save the grown up chocolate coffee
a real chocolate factory i loved it my
winner chocky wacky do doll so bad for
you so delicious i'm obsessed and we had
such a good day there yeah
[Music]
oh
[Music]